i think that you want to improve the
quality of life for transgenders and i
think you want society to be as
functional and tolerant as possible i
believe that's your objective and that's
certainly my objective um so no my
position isn't there's not enough data i
want to be very clear because i know a
lot of times people will have people
from opposing viewpoints and sort of
feign middle ground no my position is
that there is such overwhelming data
right now uh that it's not good now what
you just said there i do agree with of
course people who are bullied people who
are mistreated people who are abused
probably have increased rates of
suicidality i think we would both agree
with that but the truth is that minority
groups in general actually have lower
suicide rates for example blacks
compared to whites i don't think anyone
here would say that black people are
less likely to be victims of hate crimes
nowhere else do you find the attempted
suicide rate in society outside of
modern transgenderism